märz 2020 die griechische küstenwache
hindert geflüchtete mit gewalt daran
nach europa zu gelangen
die beamten schießen es gibt prügel
juni 2020 ein frontex schiff bringt ein
boot mit flüchtlingen ab das griechische
gewässer erreicht hat geflüchtete
berichten immer wieder dass sie von
küstenwachen aus europäischen gewässern
vertrieben werden
selbst gedrehte bilder von flüchtlingen
in rettungsinseln die griechen sollten
sich schämen
das ist unmenschlich sie haben uns in
dieses ding gesetzt und alles
weggenommen
wir können niemanden anrufen vielleicht
werden wir alle sterben und ertrinken
die eu agentur frontex soll europas
grenzen sichern muss aber geflüchtete
retten wenn die in seenot geraten
mit dabei die deutsche bundespolizei
ein boot im ägäis einsatz ist die
uckermark wir treffen einen beamten der
bundespolizei der 2020 in seinen zweiten
frontex einsatz ging über seine
erfahrungen möchte er nur anonym
sprechen
ich war schon mal im frontex einsatz und
damals war es halt so dass wir die
flüchtlinge die über die see gekommen
sind gerettet haben
und ich finde das ist eine gute sache
und deswegen habe ich mich 2020 wieder
für den einsatz gemeldet
doch nun der vorwurf frontex soll in
sogenannte push back verwickelt sein
mehrfach sollen flüchtlingsboote
abgedrängt oder aufs offene meer hinaus
gezogen worden seien
das ist verboten ein fall betrifft die
deutsche bundespolizei das deutsche
frontex schiff uckermark trifft im
august 2020 auf ein flüchtlingsboot in
griechischen gewässern 615 die uckermark
stopp vor der küste von samos ein
schlauchboot mit rund 40 geflüchteten an
bord die deutschen informieren die
griechische küstenwache
die trifft um 6 45 bei dem
flüchtlingsboot 1
die deutschen besatzungsmitglieder sehen
wie die griechen die geflüchteten an
bord nehmen die uckermark fährt zurück
die uckermark legt auf samos an
später kommt das griechische boot ohne
flüchtlinge an bord die deutschen fragen
nach doch die griechen wiegeln ab wie so
oft sagen sie sie seien nicht in push
back verwickelt griechenland in push
becks involviert absolut nicht
die griechen behaupten sie hätten keine
flüchtlinge an bord genommen
das flüchtlingsboot habe vielmehr
abgedreht in richtung türkische gewässer
der grüne europa-abgeordnete erik
marquardt ist mitglied einer
untersuchungsgruppe die den vorwürfen
gegen frontex nachgeht
es gibt inzwischen die praxis dass
frontex schiffe gar nicht mehr die
menschen aussehen und aufnehmen sondern
das nur den griechen melden sie sich
dann verziehen und man nicht genau weiß
was machen die griechen dort und dass
man dort nicht so genau hinschaut ist
glaube ich das verbrechen im laufe der
untersuchung präsentieren die griechen
eine zweite version jetzt geben sie zu
die geflüchteten zunächst an bord
genommen zu haben
die hätten aber nicht um asyl gebeten
sondern seien freiwillig richtung türkei
gefahren
[Musik]
für mich ist das ganz offensichtlich
dass es da nicht mit rechten dingen
zugeht dass die griechen ihr
unrechtmäßiges handeln vertuschen
möchten
die bundespolizei will ihre rolle beim
vorfall in der ägäis am 10 august
aufklären und kritisiert das verhalten
der griechen es ist hier nicht
ersichtlich warum die griechischen
behörden den fortgang der maßnahmen vor
ort nach übernahme nicht transparent
gegenüber den deutschen einsatzkräften
darstellen wollten
doch diese erklärung wird nie
veröffentlicht frontal21 liegt sie vor
wir fragen bei der bundespolizei nach
die teilt mit das vorgehen der deutschen
einsatzkräfte sei rechtlich nicht zu
beanstanden
der bundespolizist dagegen berichtet
dass kollegen pusch becks verharmlosen
ein kollege hat offen zugegeben dass
diese push blacks stattfinden aber
notwendig sind ich habe gesagt dass da
für mich straftaten ersichtlich sind und
ich mich nicht daran beteiligen werde
und daraufhin hat einer gesagt ob ich da
nicht falschen der bundespolizei wäre
mein vorgesetzter meint wenn die
flüchtlinge nicht um asyl bitten sei das
eine legale zurückschiebung das soll
eine grauzone wegsehen bei rechtsbrüchen
frontex chef fabrice lhenry bestreitet
das wir haben keine beweise gefunden
dass frontex beamte direkt oder indirekt
an pusch becks beteiligt waren
doch dem europaabgeordneten erik
marquardt liegen aussagen eines insiders
vor der in der frontex zentrale arbeitet
der schreibt seenotrettung habe für
frontex chef larry keine priorität
ribéry habe klargemacht frontex sei kein
teurer rettungsdienst dass man sich
offenbar verweigerten und leitung zu
betreiben und das wenn zb push back
berichtet dann vorliegen diese berichte
verzögert werden das scheint system zu
haben bei frontex und das ist etwas was
man dringend eingreifen muss
auf nachfrage bleibt frontex dabei man
habe keinerlei beweise für
menschenrechtsverletzungen gefunden
die arbeitsgruppe untersuchte aber noch
fünf vorfälle
es macht mir angst dass eine so mächtige
behörde so wenig aufklärung bei
mutmaßlichen rechtsbrüchen betreibt und
menschen so behandelt werden als ob sie
komplett wertlos wären und keine rechte
hätten
frontex chef larry sollte
menschenrechtsbeobachter einstellen
doch der insider berichtet lotterie habe
das aktiv behindert
auf nachfrage habe er sogar gesagt das
habe für ihn keine priorität
die frontex zentrale in warschau in der
der insider arbeitet auf nachfrage
verteidigt die grenzschutzbehörde die
verzögerungen
es ist besser das richtig zu machen als
den rekrutierungsprozess
durchzupeitschen
die bürgerbeauftragte der europäischen
union wirft frontex dagegen vor den
schutz der menschenrechte zu behindern
wir haben eine beschwerdeinstanz
geschaffen aber seitdem funktioniert das
nicht unsere zufriedenheit
das macht mir sorge dass wir nach so
vielen jahren immer noch probleme mit
frontex und der einhaltung von
grundrechten haben
doch horst seehofer und die anderen
eu-innenminister treten für ein hartes
frontex grenzregime 1
sie wollen das mandat von frontex voll
ausreizen und obwohl viele vorwürfe zu
specks noch nicht aufgeklärt sind legen
sich die innenminister fest
in einem internen protokoll vom januar
heißt es man habe keine verstöße gegen
bestehende europäische und
internationale regelungen des personals
bei einsätzen in der ägäis feststellen
können ich finde es schrecklich wie mit
den flüchtlingen in griechenland
umgegangen wird
ich hätte nie gedacht dass so etwas in
europa möglich ist ich schäme mich teil
des systems zu sein dass menschen
entrechtet stadt recht durchzusetzen
[Musik]